hey there fellow townscapers and welcome
back to my channel
if this is your first time here i want
to give you a big welcome and thank you
so much for coming today
please do me a favor and hit the like
button and share this video with other
people that you think may enjoy the
content this will help me out a lot and
i would really really appreciate it
if you haven't already hit that
subscribe button and the notification
bell so you don't miss anything that i
upload
so today is a great day for townscapers
everywhere and i'm going to tell you why
this morning oscar stallberg the creator
of townscaper added actual floating
cities in the game
it was tested in beta and added a couple
of hours ago and this
changes the game completely because now
not only do they float in the sky
they have propellers all of townscaper
twitter is ablaze as it should be
because it's an amazing update that was
totally worth the wait
and so today i will show you how to make
a floating base for your city
okay so this is me trying to make a
floating city
i decided to just try to work on the
middle
um but i didn't realize that i was doing
it wrong there were no propellers so i
said dang what am i doing
and i remembered oscar said that it had
to be a perfect loop in order for it to
work in order for it to activate
so i'm sitting here for about 30 minutes
living in struggle city
trying to figure out how to make a
perfect loop and it just was not working
and i was just like oh my gosh i don't
get it like i really didn't get it
um and so then i decided to myself you
know scapegoat maybe you should just try
to work with the middle
since it's a perfect circle now i
encourage you to try to work with the
entire grid to see what type of shapes
you can come up with
that have propellers but definitely is
going to have to be
some kind of loop or circle um in order
for this to work so what i did was i
just went back to what was loaded in the
beta clipboard
and i tried to work with what was there
so i made a base and i got rid of the
bottom
part and boom there we go we have
propellers so i said huh how come i
can't get it to work on other shapes
i went back to struggle city decided
that i could try again
and it did not work so i said you know
what i think i'm gonna pack up my things
and go back to not so struggle town so
here i am back in not so struggle town
or should we call it not so struggle
island
and i built a base and then i built a
second level to the base
and then after i built that base i'm
gonna show you what i did
all i did was made two levels worth of a
base got rid of the first level
and there was nothing but cobblestone
floating and the propellers appeared
so i said oh my gosh oh my gosh i did it
so now i'm gonna try to make one in the
sky
so i went on ahead and i filled the base
after a while i got tired of filling the
base and i just went on ahead and
did a tower if you want to take your
time building a base that's cool but if
you want to get down to the nitty gritty
you can go on ahead and just build a
tower
so that way you can build around the
tower after you build around the tower
you'll be able to see the results uh of
course remember you need that perfect
looper that perfect circle
in order for it to work so i went ahead
and i built that top base
um and it's floating so now i'm gonna
build a city on it so you guys can just
get an idea of
what you can do with this update i think
it's really really amazing
i think oscar did a great job on this as
you can see the lighting is slightly
different we can talk about that too
as well because right now i'm in beta um
so i can show you guys that how that
works out
it's really cool if you want to see the
ins and outs of the game i think it's
amazing
okay so this is the end result nothing
too crazy something simple just to show
you what the update is capable of
i'm really really excited about this
like i'm so stoked i just
just wow it's amazing to me so i'm
really excited i'm gonna have a fun week
this week
you guys as oscar would say go build
some towns take this
run with it build some floating castles
or cities or whatever your heart desires
so let's get into the beta real quick as
you can see i'm adjusting the lighting
and there is what i call a day in a
night mode i'm not sure if that's what
oscar calls it please don't quote me
i'll probably correct myself in the
description a little later but yes this
is nighttime mode the lights come on in
the window and that is adorable
you can also change it to where the
daylight moves as in real
like in real life you can see the
shadows are moving with the sunlight and
i just think that is so amazing you can
make it brighter you can make it dimmer
whatever your heart desires have fun
with that also you can see the nooks and
crannies if you will
you can invert that please once again
please don't quote me
i know i sound weird trying to describe
all this stuff but i don't know what
it's called okay this is my first time
on beta
you can also see what i'm assuming is
the poly model of these builds of the
buildings this is what it looks like
when it's being created
so this is something really really cool
you can see the ins and outs with them
without the textures some really fun
stuff
anyways you guys thank you so much for
stopping by i really appreciate it
if you want to check out beta i'll have
the instructions in the description
below
thank you for stopping by and viewing
please make sure you like subscribe and
share if you want to continue to support
me for free you can click on the links
down below again thank you for stopping
by
i really really appreciate it and i'll
see y'all next time